[Music]
that is my favorite 15 seconds from the
Godfather these few shots of Michael
Corleone II lighting a cigarette and his
reaction are a great example of how the
subtext of a story can create powerful
moments of character development that
are purely visual let's dive into this
moment its relationship to the story as
a whole and breakdown why I think it's
so powerful this video is brought to you
by my new podcast Stream theory
subscribe wherever you listen to
podcasts The Godfather
among other things is a story about
Michael Corleone's transformation how
does a character get from here that's my
family cares to hear Michael's arc
through the story is powerful and
well-developed
Al Pacino's performance plays a big role
in making it feel realistic and
motivated that's mixed up in drugs I'm
talking about a dishonest cop a crooked
cop who got mixed up in the rackets
and got what was coming but the
impressive thing here is that there are
almost no scenes where Michael talks
about how he's feeling about his
transformation instead we see how he
changes over the course of the story
the lighter moment is one of the few
pivotal moments that show his transition
after this scene Michael decisively
takes action placing himself as a part
of the family this shift from someone
who wants to separate himself from the
actions of his family as my family cares
- one who wants to take action feels
motivated because several clues are
given to the audience about his personal
internal transformation leading up to
the moment where he says he wants to
take action the first clue is the
distance he places between himself and
Kay either in an attempt to protect her
or to avoid her scrutiny because he
knows he's going to become more involved
with the family he starts separating
himself from her yeah I know
I can't talk the separation is made
clear visually in this scene where he
makes a call to see if his father is
alive and through the composition in
this scene go back to New Hampshire and
I'll call you at your parents house
where kay is composed with open space in
the frame towards Michael but Michael's
composition shifts from this to this
with empty space away from her as if
she's being deliberately framed out the
separation between them is again
emphasized as Michael steps fully into
the role of Godfather at the end of the
film and so we can read these earlier
moments of separation as a development
towards that end let's go back to
lighting a cigarette this is another
major clue of Michael's internal
transformation but how does it get us
from here to here when Michael goes to
visit his father at the hospital he
finds him unguarded and exposed to a
second attempt on his life
Sonny Michael I'm at the hospital listen
I got here late there's nobody here
nobody no no Cassio's men the detectives
nobody Papa's all alone I won't panic he
has to take action but in this situation
his action is reactionary he's stepping
up but he doesn't have much of a choice
put your hand in your pocket like you
have a gun
maybe alright Michael's family sees him
as a civilian what are you going to the
city sent somebody guys would I'm just
gonna my send somebody with him I'll be
alright so Lozano's uses a civilian on
the steps outside the hospital he stands
pretending to be a guard with another
civilian who came to visit his father
they hold their bluff and the would-be
assassins back down this moment leaves
one of the two civilians shaken he's
unable to light his cigarette Michaels
hands however are steady this piece of
information alone informs the audience
about how Michael is feeling at that
moment but what's more significant is
the emphasis on Michael noticing his own
emotional state the shot of him looking
at the lighter cues us into the fact
that he's noticing and thinking about
why his hands are steady the audience
and Michael are pondering what it might
mean that he can face this kind of
danger and remain unfazed and to me this
is the moment when Michael realizes that
he wants to be involved that he doesn't
have a problem taking action as a part
of the family he doesn't express that
verbally until later it takes his family
a while to catch up to where he's at in
eternally hey what are you gonna do nice
college boy yeah they want to get mixed
up in the family business now you want
to gun down a police captain one cuz he
slapped in the face a little bit and his
full transformation from civilian to
mobster takes the rest of the movie but
right here is the first real indication
we have that his mind has changed it's a
hinge on which Michael's transformation
pivots we see signs of the
transformation earlier on but before
this moment Michael is reactionary and
after this moment he begins to initiate
action
on his own but how can all of that be
communicated so quickly we can see
Michael thinking over what just happened
this is emphasized in the performance
both on his face and how slowly he
closes as a lighter but it's also
emphasized through the pacing in the
Edit but choosing to linger on the
lighter for a small beat before and
after he closes it instead of cutting on
the action as would be common for a
simple insert meant just to show the
action here's the moment as we see it in
the film
[Music]
now watch how much it changes the
feeling of the moment
if I remove just a few frames before and
after the action of closing the lighter
a few seconds difference in the pace can
change the subtextual meaning of the
shot you might even notice a continuity
error in this little moment in this shot
the hand holding the cigarette starts
moving and in the next shot it hasn't
moved my Reata even fixes this and cuts
on the action following the rules of
continuity but continuity doesn't matter
here because the emotional content of
the pace is more important and this is
what I love about film and why I love
this moment specifically because of the
powerful subtlety that's available if
you set things up correctly you can use
moments that would otherwise be small
and insignificant to communicate
something very meaningful or even
critical to the story it's the kind of
moment that's specific to film in a way
that's difficult to replicate in other
mediums these 15 seconds are a tiny
moment compared to many of the grandiose
examples of excellent filmmaking that
exists in The Godfather but that's why
it's my favorite it's not a big
memorable moment there's no quotable
line many people won't even notice
consciously what it's communicating but
it illustrates how just two actors a
lighter and 15 seconds can communicate
as much emotionally as the larger more
impressive moments in the film stream
theory is a new podcast I started with
fellow youtuber Jackson from skip intro
each month we talked about the
increasingly complex world of streaming
services and what the streaming wars
mean for the content that we all love to
watch in our latest episode we talked
about the release of Disney Plus and the
mandalorian go to stream theory
podcast.com to listen or subscribe on
iTunes Spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts special thank you to my patrons
for their support of my channel if you
support my channel for $5 a month you
get access to the monthly bonus video
that I make these more informal video
essays have included a tour of Irish
cinema
a frame-by-frame look at the animation
style of into the spider verse and how
aspect-ratio created challenges for
remastering the wire if you're
interested in getting access to these
rewards and supporting my channel go to
patreon.com/scishow